yo what is up everybody Mather we G here
with another Dark Souls 3 tutorial now
in this video I'm gonna be showing you
guys the location of the crows and how
to get to them if you don't know what
the crows are the crows are our system
for trading items in Dark Souls they've
been I think in every Dark Souls game
and there are certain items you can only
get by trading with the crows so it is
an important part of the game that you
don't want to overlook so to do this
you're going to need 20,000 souls or
some really good jumping skills the
first way I'm gonna show you how to do
it is with these Souls the second way is
with the jumping skills so get 20k souls
go to Firelink shrine go to the
handmaiden of the shrine and buy her key
that costs 20,000 souls now once you do
this you're gonna head up to the main
steps and go up the steps around the
shrine to the right of the shrine and go
outside there should be a big tree take
a left and head on up to the locked
tower this is the opposite side of the
Firelink shrine to where the katana guy
is at the start of the game so go up to
the locked door the key will open the
door go up the tower go on to the bridge
and then just jump off onto the building
of Firelink shrine once you do this
knock down the ladder so that you can
get back up you're easy anytime and head
over to the middle of the circular area
of the roof of the shrine and you should
see the nest here the birds start going
all crazy and there you go you have
found the location of where to trade
items so if you want to trade an item
just walk up to the nest and drop the
item that you want to trade on to the
nest not all items are tradable and the
crows will tell you if they like it and
if they don't and if they do like it
then just wait for them to exchange it
and pick it up it happens
instantaneously so you don't need to
save them quit it just happens right
there when you're there and that is how
you get to be crows the more legitimate
method now the second method is not
going to be using the 20k souls key
however you will probably eventually
want to get that key since there is some
cool stuff in the other tower that you
do need the key to access so if you
don't want to get the key yet or you
don't have enough souls to yet you're
going to continue on the same path from
filing shrine up to the tower except
when you get near the tower go to the
small tree over to the side near the
building of Firelink shrine you're gonna
run up the street and jump to the right
on to the building now this jump took me
many many tries it is not an easy jump
in my opinion but hey maybe I'm just bad
at jumping so you're gonna rub the
treat and jump to the side and keep
doing that until you get it like I do in
the video and then you're up so you're
gonna run to the front of the shrine on
the level you're at and there should be
a opening to go into the ceiling area of
the shrine I don't think there is a
secret wall there's this you wall later
on and the ceiling of the shrine I'm not
gonna show that in the video since it
doesn't have anything to do with the
nest but once you get to the ceiling of
the shrine inside the shrine go up into
that and go to the middle of it and you
should hear the crows again see some of
the feathers and sticks and same thing
as I said before in the video of how to
trade items it's gonna be the same drop
right where they're talking and then
move back see if they like it if they do
they'll trade and there you go so that
has been my video tutorial of how to get
to the crows in Dark Souls 3 I hope you
have enjoyed if you have make sure you
check out more of my channel since I
will be posting a lot more Dark Souls 3
content I already have one video up of
how to upgrade your Estus flask so if
you don't have to do that go check that
out thank you for watching and peace out